[Music]
penis buildings are they training are
they training with actual lightsabers
did they set sabers to stun this just
seems insanely dangerous i get that the
empire's design philosophy is primarily
based around intimidation but how does
intimidating your own workers with fall
hazards help with all the star
destroying we got her joe has everyone
waiting around with baited breath as if
she's already a leader in the rebel
alliance so i'll remind you that the
concern around leia's fate has to do
with her detailed knowledge of the path
and not necessarily her well-being and i
know this because not a single one of
these [ __ ] asks about wade hajja
what are you doing here the writer's
internal monologue regarding why haja is
in this episode somehow makes it into
the show we used to know trade route to
get them out but the windows closing we
held it to help you get the kid
we only have a few hours if this was
such a timely need then seems like he
could have explained this to ben on the
trip here might have even been able to
formulate some sort of plan so once you
landed you were ready to get everyone
off in that small window of time what is
josh makowins would say if he were
writing for tv sins but you didn't do
that did you if we seal them in now they
can hold out for days oh no not days and
patience may be a virtue of the dark
side but it makes for a very dull
character motivation obi-wan has moved
to action by this conveniently placed
jedi paraphernalia instead of being
suspicious about the owner of this
extensive collection of lightsabers
isn't the patience for siege how do you
know whenever i run into my siblings i
also flash back to a fight to the almost
death but that doesn't excuse the absurd
fact that this one singular sparring
match somehow manages to be the perfect
analogy for every event that occurs in
this episode but we do not need to fight
them we just need to hold them off long
enough to get you all out and by hold
them off you mean fight them right
broken how much time do you need to
override the doors three four hours you
have one did ben just pull a captain
kirk on rokin did he just scotty rockin
i think he just scottied all over rokin
showa so over a minute of runtime on
this rushing about an overly dramatic
preparation in an attempt to get us
invested in the standoff and hoping we
wouldn't notice that the rebels plan
hinges on the empire with its endless
supply of red shirts only attacking one
of the two known doors and spoiler alert
this works the empire sees a big ass
door on the roof that happens to be the
size of a spaceship and not even vader
himself thinks to send a ship a
stormtrooper or even a droid to check it
out and maybe wait there in case they
try to use it
that was underwhelming faja could be my
padawan at tv sins i'm a little too big
to be crawling around in the vents would
you like to try i'm going to need a
ladder going out of your way to create
obstacles that only leia can overcome
doesn't change the fact that her
character was the worst idea this show
had and to be clear vivian lyra blair is
very charming and makes her role work
better than it should but we're still
stuck with an obi-wan helps protect a
kid cliche and that kinda sucks dude she
asks you trust me
i trust her obi-wan acts as if this is a
matter of trust and not a question about
whether leia has the required electrical
engineering knowledge to complete the
task i am not a babysitter ben i have to
go forcing someone to babysit your child
or any child you're in charge of looking
after not cool ben not [ __ ] cool i'm
not sure if two incidents make it cliche
but it's super [ __ ] weird both this
show and mandalorian have a plot line
that requires the smallest character to
venture into a space full of wires that
they have to [ __ ] with if he's found you
if he's learned of the children but once
again how does vader not know about the
children one's living with his uncle
without a name change and once in a
royal family making daily public
appearances this show has made darth
vader so much less intimidating and so
much more stupid why did you do that
obi-wan i can assure you we no longer
need your help if i don't hear from you
soon
i'm surprised you're not already there
based on the movies and all the shows so
far everyone ends up at tattooing
eventually you know i was following
orders on gorilla
[Music]
14 people died and six of them were
children and i couldn't do anything to
help them so now i do this you pull your
gun out of your holster you're right ben
some things you can't forget like this
show oh who am i kidding i forget about
this show as soon as the credits start
if this is you stalling for time it
won't work well we still end up with one
more episode so if rifa could have done
this the whole time then what was she
waiting for you're telling me the
standoff couldn't have been over five
minutes ago [ __ ] you show and the horses
you stop and look at for 10 minutes
before writing in on looking at this
wall of stormtroopers i find it
completely unbelievable that obi and his
band of misfits have missed a single
shot i thought the only place they
taught this kind of marksmanship was the
stormtrooper academy
but still rokin survives running around
in the middle of the crossfire despite
the interesting fight going on in the
background let's just focus on this guy
swinging a pipe at blaster fire
show pew pews on for all the neverending
how are they gonna get out of this one
cliche expecting us to believe a
stormtrooper hit something he or she was
aiming at and on behalf of humanity i
will exclaim with a resounding cry we do
not believe you writers give ned b the
wade treatment i'll assume at least half
of you said who and the answer is yes
interrupting your protagonist as he
deals with death to briefly revisit your
strange comedic child fixes a garage
door b plot it's over this kicks off the
most confusing exchange of dialogue in
the entire series where rokin tries to
convince obi-wan not to quit and obi-wan
tries to convince roken that he's not
quitting meaning they're on the same
page the entire time and the whole thing
was unnecessary and over-dramatic you
wanna tell me
are you gonna fight without a weapon
there are other ways to fight
so
no then this isn't over yet what the
episode yeah we know
again i have to point out that this
lightsaber practice really feels like
they're trying to lightly kill each
other so it'd go a long way if the show
could indicate whether or not these
things are nerf or if these two are
oddly okay with being cut in half
[Applause]
i made a joke about this previously so
it's completely uncanny that lola
actually tries to adorable leia to death
here also the show never acknowledges
that leia is the one that brought lola
along on this adventure which makes it
her fault all these people just died in
that blaster fight seriously lots of
casualties on both sides all leia's
fault
well that was anticlimactic also if evil
lola planned to stop leia from opening
the roof then why did it wait till she
found the spot she needed to reopen the
roof
the plan was to leave as soon as
possible right so why are all these
people not already on the transport this
is cool but not as cool as starkiller
pulling down a star destroyer so points
will be deducted accordingly
neat trick but couldn't vader just have
easily stopped the second ship by using
the force as well was he too tired did
he need some orange slices how does
anakin not stop this with some quick
stabby stab action show wants me to
believe that a weaponless obi twice
armed with only break dance moves is a
match for darth later and his lightsaber
so bob you telling me vader's finally
gonna get to where bin is in this
episode man that sounds exciting what
are you gonna have him do i don't know
stan i figured we'd have him stare a lot
at the end people really love to see
other people behind mass staring into
the distance we've done focus groups on
it and everything
[Music]
seems like vader saw this coming for a
while now but still rivas certainly
didn't help her cause by loudly grunting
and deploying her saber at the moment of
attack completely undermining all her
sneaking there are two things i know for
sure about this sequence one is that
vader has his back to riva twice and
doesn't get stabbed the other is if you
freeze the frame at exactly the right
moment it looks like vader's penis and
butthole both have lightsabers coming
out of them your rage was useful was it
though because there's still no closer
to having kenobi or leia i know they're
saving the chase for the next episode
but this transport ship flying off with
no resistance from the star destroyer in
orbit is all kinds of the nonsense a
hyperdrive is down story got a story
even when it's a contrivance
guess it wouldn't be a star wars series
if we didn't go back to the [ __ ]
desert
well the only way out of here is to try
one of these doors
one of them leads to the castle at the
center of the labyrinth and the other
one leads to
certain death
[Music]
oh there you are
i think this is the beginning of a
beautiful friendship set a course for
earth maximum warp
[Music]
hear ye hear ye
ye old town crier proclaimed crappy by
all
jesus homer simpson and he shall rock
thy world
light them up let's show this
prehistoric [ __ ] how we do things
downtown it's a heavy gun there's that
word again heavy
why are things so heavy in the future is
there a problem with the earth's
gravitational pull
is everything all right
i wet my bed
hello third sister
people keep asking if i'm back
and i haven't really had an answer
but now yeah
i'm thinking on back